welcome to see you're playing java chip
three from the US team the four nights
that's not very exciting how well if
okay the good old Italian four nights
which after 90 form is already quite
quite nice or black I mean nothing
nothing super great but like definitely
has no problem but it's this guy doing
here reinventing this can I'll tell me
that you've never seen that before I
think this is not I can take and click
wind shot rifles or here that's that's
already a very borderline for white I
mean borderline losing you know night
hanks and g 2 eggs and now let's just
think about it for just a moment and in
bishop age 3 when they exchange but is
there something better you bishop a six
is also very interesting Bishop e6 d3 if
I take it that's this the night hanging
on c6 and I'm threatening to take on f1
now that's that sets that's even better
I'd that's even better
yeah but that's even better d 383 the
night hangs and I'm threatening also
Queen f 1 and D take C 2 we are less
than taking the night now buddy which
was relatively speaking the best but ok
this is just a piece check no come on
check yeah you're only going to play
this end game a piece down run really ok
here it is so rook takes Bishop takes
this also not bad wins wins another
exchange
white resides okay it was his second
five minute game so this rating is
probably very inflated on it's simply
not inflated but it's not getting
established rating so i was a bit with
mystified well maybe p is probably just
far weaker player that summer stumbled
into this this pairing yeah it's still
useful to see that where is this is not
a good opening simply because of night
XD form after that black has already em
yeah equalized very comfortably the
relatively best that white can do is to
do this d5 and now Bishop to d3 this is
quite okay still about equal probably
hear black take 56 and this is in about
equal position there's also this funny
possibility that's also quite nice ok B
should be five yeah this is simply not
working I'm there's also this Queen g5
is the same the same business I'm going
to take here and here why this just just
falling apart with various line some in
Bishop h3 is one can even you can know
all that but Bishop age reassess is
simplest really um Bishop t6 is also
good going for for this for this motif
yeah it is it is simply not not play
about this if we here okay Bishop g4
it's also good this is even the best
when it wins the Queen okay but I was
thinking that this is not bad because
takes like this and if he tries to to to
to sit to to save the night let's say
here my intention was to do this check
and get the Queen back like that with a
with an extra look yeah this was my idea
okay this was maybe a warning for some
this opening is really not very
promising for white thanks for watching